the federal reserve is expected to raise
interest rates this week in an attempt
to curb some of the highest inflation
the nation has experienced in years
gasoline prices average 4.33 cents per
gallon that's up
1.51 cents from last year another
problem for the nation's economy
american businesses unable to find
enough workers chris vancleave reports
on the trouble spot
there's a big problem playing out in
little lytle texas outside san antonio
work installing this roof on the town's
high school is moving slowly but it's
not a shortage of supplies it's a
shortage of manpower so at the end of
the year we may hire 12 people
and through attrition we're losing more
than 12 people despite salaries hitting
the six figures brad belden's roofing
company can't find enough roofers the
construction industry is dirty dangerous
and difficult
and american workers aren't interested
in doing that has it gotten worse during
the pandemic it's gotten considerably
worse belden is the third generation to
run his family business and while hiring
has never been easy it's especially hard
now nationwide there are around 800
thousand open construction jobs it's
gotten so bad he's passing on some work
just as demand for housing and warehouse
space is surging
the worker shortage is on display at
this project here they have about 25
percent of the people they would
normally have working on this high
school roof and that means the project
will take three to four times as long to
finish
unable to find enough american workers
belden has used the government's h-2b
guest worker visa program since 2007 to
bring in qualified roofers from abroad
but there's more demand than visas in
2017 congress allowed for up to 130 000
to be awarded annually but tens of
thousands go unissued each year by the
government leaving many jobs unfilled to
not use all of these visas is a major
disservice to the economy cato institute
research fellow david beer estimates
those unused visas cost the economy two
billion dollars a year when businesses
can't
hire the labor that they need that cost
gets passed on to the consumer of the
product the business is trying to supply
we already have a workplace shortage
maine congresswoman shelly pingree is
proposing legislation to expand the h-2b
visa program the bill has more than 70
bipartisan co-sponsors but the program
faces opposition from labor unions and
immigration reform has stalled for years
in congress would it be better for the
economy to dictate how many guest
workers come in there's no reason it
shouldn't be a more open process and the
supply shouldn't be allowed to meet the
demand
jobs currently going unfilled on
projects getting harder to complete for
cbs saturday morning i'm chris vancleave
in lytle texas